je pars du principe ou une agence doit
servir à quelque chose et j'ai pas
d'intérêt à vous dire ça mais je vais je
il faut être honnête si on prend une
commission sur les influenceurs c'est
aussi parce qu'on doit leur apporter
quelque chose donc je pense que cette
aide juridique est importante c'est à
dire que si on donne un placement de
produit frauduleux à un influenceur
l'agence doit aussi être responsable et
et c'est pas dans mon intérêt de le dire
mais c'est une vérité et c'est une
réalité l'agence si elle donne un
placement elle doit être aussi
responsable influenceur aussi
irresponsable parce que c'est trop
facile de dire c'est l'agence c'est
l'agence moi je sais que on a eu des
influenceurs qui nous ont dit moi je
fais tout et n'importe quoi et puis on a
des influenceurs qui nous ont toujours
dit non ça je ne fais pas c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'on fait nous on propose
aux influenceurs les sites internet donc
on les valide d'abord au juridique
ensuite on les propose aux influenceurs
et les influenceurs disent oui ou non
ils ont une totale liberté sur ce qu'il
propose donc influenceurs n'a pas envie
ou ne se sent pas de présenter ce
produit là il a la liberté de dire non
mais si il dit oui et que il se trouve
que c'est un placement frauduleux alors
dans le cas où l'agence parce qu'il peut
aussi que l'agence était trompée ça nous
est arrivé aussi ou on a vérifié le site
il était légal tout était carré les
conditions générales étaient parfaites
tout est nickel vous faites la promotion
de ce site et le site ferme une semaine
après dans ces cas-là qui est
responsable l'agence qui a tout contrôlé
où tout est nickel ou le site internet
qui est venu dans la volonté d'arnaquer
les gens et y compris l'agence puisqu'on
a même pas été payé non plus des
prestations donc je pense que à ça doit
servir aussi des enquêtes et des des
enquêtes de la DGCCRF ou si on
promotionne un site qui n'est pas
juridiquement
légal il y a une responsabilité de
l'agence à avoir voilà mais si le site
est légal après on peut pas non plus
être derrière la tête des gens enfin
derrière la tête de tout le monde c'est
pas possible c'est c'est clair voilà
mais il faut qu'on propose des sites
carrés voilà et chacun doit assumer ses
responsabilités